[Musica]
[Applauso]
il professor stephen hawking è stato un
fisico di fama mondiale tra le tante
cose importanti cioè ha detto e scritto
una cosa che mi ha stupito è stata una
lettera aperta da lui pubblicata insieme
ad altri scienziati nel 2015 sui rischi
per il futuro dell'umanità dello
sviluppo incontrollato dall'artificio
scelta intelligente dell'intelligenza
artificiale
a me sembrava una posizione un po
allarmista da un grande uomo di scienza
poi soprattutto da una persona che era
l'esempio vivente più chiaro dei
benefici dell'intelligenza artificiale
ma lui consentiva di comunicare col
mondo esterno essendo affetto da una
grave malattia dei motoneuroni
dobbiamo dunque avere paura
dell'intelligenza artificiale
quali saranno gli impatti economici e
sociali di questa tecnologia come
modificherà il nostro modo di essere e
di vivere di pensare
queste sono alcune delle domande qui
cerchiamo di dare una risposta che al
centro comune di ricerca per alcune
questioni come l'impatto sociale ed
economico non possiamo ancora dare una
risposta perché sono fenomeni che stanno
giusto partendo a destra per questo ci
siamo dotati di un centro europeo di
analisi dell'intelligenza artificiale in
modo da poter dare in tempi brevi delle
risposte infornateli su altre questioni
però qualche idea ce l'abbiamo già ed è
di questo che vi voglio parlare ma in
prima cosa che cos'è l'intelligenza
artificiale in realtà parliamo di
sistemi che noi diciamo intelligenti
perché possono osservare il loro
ambiente e sulla base di questo prendere
delle decisioni o delle azioni in modo
abbastanza autonomo per arrivare a degli
obiettivi prefissati
le applicazioni oggi più comune
riguardano la robotica industriale il
riconoscimento di
immagini video testo noi già li usiamo
normalmente nei nostri telefoni
cellulari o né gli assistenti personali
con alex siri non è che stiamo parlando
di qualcosa di totalmente nuovo in
realtà sono tecniche statistiche che
hanno cominciato a svilupparsi già dagli
anni 50 quello che è successo però negli
ultimi 6 7 anni e che c'è stato da un
lato una crescita velocissima della
capacità di calcolo dei processori
questi raddoppiano in potenza ogni 18 24
mesi
ma soprattutto c'è stato uno sviluppo
ancora superiore dei dati in formato
digitale
voglio darvi un esempio quella che
vedete è un'immagine della british
library è una delle due unipi
biblioteche più grandi al mondo contiene
più di 150 milioni di oggetti in
catalogo si sviluppa su 14 piani ea
scaffali lunghi 600 chilometri come
l'autostrada da milano a roma
adesso immaginate milioni e milioni e
milioni di british hybris una in cima
all'art questa vita l'idea del volume di
dati che viene creato ogni anno con lo
sviluppo di miliardi di nuovi sensori
addosso in casa in alto in ufficio in
strada tutti connessi tra di loro via
internet
questo stesso volume di dati verrà
creato ogni giorno questo vuol dire ogni
giorno creare tanti dati quanto l'intera
storia dell'umanità è chiaro che noi
come umani non potremmo mai dare un
senso a questa mole di dati per questo
abbiamo bisogno sempre di più i sistemi
automatici che in qualche modo filtrino
tutti questi dati en estraggano dei da
delle informazioni che sono utili per
noi il tipo di sviluppo che si sta
avvicinando già ora vedrà sempre di più
delle applicazioni utili soprattutto
quelli in tempo reale
dai conducenti dalle automobili senza
conducente alla medicina a livello
cellulare cioè diretta alla singola
cellula malata all agricoltura di
precisione dove quindi passando il
trattore alldro ne misura pianta per
pianta e addirittura foglia per foglia
per vedere se hai bisogno di un po più
d'acqua un po più di pesticida un po più
di fertilizzante con un chiaro beneficio
per l'ambiente invece che spruzzare
tutto in modo indiscriminato
il fatto che noi si dipenda sempre di
più da intelligenza artificiale per dare
un senso a questa mole di dati vuol dire
che c'è già oggi una grossa competizione
a livello globale soprattutto tra stati
uniti e cina con due modelli di sviluppo
diverso negli stati uniti sono grosse
società del web google amazon microsoft
app che hanno preso la leadership
quindi il modello di sviluppo e quello
del profitto commerciale in cina è lo
stato che ha un ruolo fondamentale sia
per le linee di indirizzo sia per
l'investimento in ricerca sia per
l'allineamento che è riuscito a creare
tra l'impresa pubblica
l'impresa privata e anche l'applicazione
militare
alla base di tutto questo c'è il
controllo dei dati in cina lo stato a di
diritto l'accesso ai dati personali
degli 800 milioni di utenti di internet
per questo ha già oggi la leadership nel
software di riconoscimento facciale
l'obiettivo dichiarato è di poter
riconoscere ogni cittadino cinese un
miliardo e 400mila
lunedì persone in meno di 3 secondi dare
poi a ciascuno un punteggio basato sia
sul comportamento nella vita fisica che
su quella virtuale in modo tale che è
base di questo punteggio vengano erogati
o meno certi servizi quindi questa è una
forma di controllo sociale dello stato
ma non è solo questo per la cina lo
sviluppo dell'intelligenza artificiale
un valore strategico perché estratto di
passare da uno sviluppo economico basato
sulla produzione di massa basso costo ha
una produzione invece di alto valore
aggiunto e di alto valore tecnologico
per questo già oggi il 57 per cento dei
brevetti sono ambientati in cina
l'obiettivo della strategia cinese di
essere leader mondiale per il 20 30
da un lato loro invece le multinazionali
americane rastrellano dati da tutto il
mondo
basta pensare che l'ottanta per cento di
tutte le ricerche su internet passa da
google
stiamo parlando di 70.000 al secondo
facebook a 2,2 miliardi di utenti al
mese
facebook e google da soli hanno
investito nel 2017 30 miliardi di
dollari in ricerca e sviluppo
queste tre volte maggiore dei budget
annuale di ricerca dell'unione europea
investimenti dati e ricerca fanno sì che
queste società sappiano tutto di noi
conoscono i nostri gusti le nostre spese
dove abitiamo dove lavoriamo
chi sono i nostri amici e possono anche
predire in modo molto accurato come
faremo dopo
per cui vendono questi dati a terzi che
poi ci offrono dei servizi
personalizzati ovvero ritagliano la loro
offerta sulla base di quella che sanno
essere la nostra domanda ma il passo
successivo e di modificare la nostra
domanda stessa
pertanto vedete che regolarmente adesso
viene raccomandato anche albergo andare
che ristorante andare che libro leggere
che mosca ascoltare chi seguire di chi
fidarsi e adesso di recente avete visto
che vi dicono anche per chi votare
anche questa è una forma di controllo
sociale però da parte del capitale
invece che dello styling e l'europa in
tutto questo che cosa fa
l'europa ha dei punti di forza a una
forte ricerca ha dei punti di leadership
nella robotica industriale in alcuni
settori industriali come l'automotive e
come in generale anche la medicina
l'europa sta cercando di trovare tra
questi due modelli di sviluppo cinese
l'americano il suo modello basato
soprattutto sulle tic a e sui principi
fondativi dell'unione europea ovvero i
diritti dell'uomo
e i principi democratici tutti i paesi
dell'unione si rendono conto che da soli
non ce la faranno
per cui hanno già firmato un protocollo
politico di accordo per lavorare insieme
allo sviluppo dell'intensa intelligenza
artificiale proprio per non essere solo
un una colonia digitale in balia ad
altri
l'unione europea si è dotata di dicembre
scorso anche di un progetto e un piano
coordinato di sviluppo per
l'intelligenza artificiale che ha
l'ambizione di investire 20 miliardi di
euro all'anno per dieci anni proprio per
fare sì che questa tecnologia venga
presa in tutti i settori economici che
ci si prepari da un punto di vista
sociale ed economico e anche per dotarsi
di un quadro etico e legale anche noi al
centro comune di ricerca abbiamo
contribuito con un nostro studio a
questo piano e abbiamo fatto anche delle
proposte che sono state recepite nel
piano affinché lo sviluppo di questa
tecnologia offra delle opportunità per
ridurre le disuguaglianze sociali e non
aumentarle vi chiederete però ma com'è
che c'è così tanta attenzione all'etica
dell'intelligenza artificiale
ora dovete sapere che un gruppo di
esperti ha già formulato quelli devono
essere i principi di base ovvero
l'intelligenza artificiale dovrebbe
agire per fare del bene evitare di fare
del male a individui a gruppi o
all'ambiente mantenere il controllo e
l'autonomia dell'individuo e anche
essere giusta trasparente e non
discriminatoria molto bello se però voi
aprite il giornale o accendete la
televisione oggi giorno mi sembra che di
comportamenti etici in giro non e le
dette così tanti quindi perché prestare
così tanta attenzione ai principi etici
dell'intelligenza artificiale e perché
noi sappiamo che tecnologia e società
lavorano insieme noi costruiamo una
tecnologia ma la tecnologia poi ci
influenza e quindi i valori che noi
poniamo nella tecnologia scriviamo nel
software sono i nostri valori quindi
dobbiamo stare bene attenti cosa ci
mettiamo dentro per tirare le fila
l'intelligenza artificiale offre grandi
opportunità ma anche qualche rischio il
fatto che chi controlla questa
tecnologia controlla al futuro e alla
base di tutto sta al controllo dei dati
vuol dire che tutti dobbiamo renderci
conto è più consapevoli dell'importanza
di dare valori dati europei per delle
applicazioni europee e questa è
chiaramente una responsabilità di
governo ed industria ma anche di noi
tutti come cittadini dobbiamo essere più
responsabili dei nostri dati privati ea
chi diamo fiducia affinché essi vengano
trattati il fatto che il futuro non si
sa ancora definito che ci sia incertezza
sulle impatto economico e sociale di
questa tecnologia non ci deve spaventare
vuol dire che il futuro non è ancora
scritto sta a noi tutti farlo usando
soprattutto la nostra di intelligenza
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]